hey guys welcome to this third edition
of my hair academia recap now today I'm
gonna explain the best and most handsome
type of nomu that exists beauty is in
the eye of the beholder people the
higher nomás are the key thing that will
ensure the villains eventually beat the
heroes and I say this because if you
take them out of the equation I mean the
heroes yeah they'll still be outmatched
but they'd at least have a chance but
these type of numbers just make it in my
mind at least make it impossible for the
heroes to win especially when you
consider the fact that twice can just
make copies of them like it just becomes
very messy anyway let's get into what
makes them so much better and I'll do my
best to avoid anything that people might
consider to be a real spoiler so the
high ends are a special breed that
possess many many advantages over
regular no Moo's so starting with what
they all have in common each possess
some form of intelligence and are
actually able to hold a conversation
this high end right here was aware of
the existence of hero rankings and they
were even able to identify a pro hero by
name finally putting those big brains to
use on this intelligence allows them to
make very tactical decisions in battle
as we saw in the pro hero hog they're
very self-aware and they know their own
weaknesses all the higher numbers that
we've seen in the manga so far have
possessed super regeneration this
essentially means even if they get hit
really badly they can just regenerate
within a matter of seconds one of them
was even able to regenerate its entire
body when only its head remained we also
saw this regeneration happen in a more
recent chapter so basically if you don't
destroy them at their weak spot then I
hate to break it to you but you have no
chance absolutely no chance but on the
topic of weak spots
so the weak spot for at least one higher
nomu was this brain I guess that's where
all the magic happens and I think it's
safe to assume that this weakness also
applies to the others because if it
didn't apply then these guys are even
more invincible than I thought on the
basis that their brain is the weak spot
there is this one higher noon with it
seemingly has discovered this guy right
here I mean he has a freaking hard hat I
tweeted the other day that this one was
particularly menacing he even has shoes
for Christ's sake
is it possible that this is what's left
of crimson riot I'd personally love if
crimson riot was just retired and living
out his life in Fiji or somewhere but
I'd say the odds of him being this high
know mu or garganta macchia far outweigh
that
possibility but this isn't a crimson
right theory video so let's get back to
the matter at hand just like normal
numbers higher numbers have a range of
multiple quirks for example we've seen
the ability to store regular no moves
inside them and also we saw muscle
augmentation which was a replication of
musculus quark this plays into the fact
that dr. o jogo can steal people's
quarks and then replicate them in his
lab this is how he was able to give
twice his duplication quark to one of
his pet sighs no Moo's and it's also how
he was able to essentially take all four
ones power of being able to live forever
seemingly and use it on himself and he
also used this replication in the minor
academia movie as we seen from the
trailers as the new villain 9 seems to
possess all for one what makes these no
mood really special is that they each
have an individual personality of their
own this personality seems to be derived
from the victim who was actually turned
into the no moose we know this because
the first higher number that we
encountered was obsessed with fighting
the strongest person he could find and
we later found out that his body was
created from a street fighter who was
obsessed with fighting be strongest upon
as possible similarly and - spoiler
alert here
curry Giri is a nomu as well which kind
of makes sense because his eyes are
exactly like some of the higher enemies
it could be arguing in fact that kira
giri is in fact the highest of higher
numbers anyway he has a really caring
personality at least regarding Shigure
Aki and I won't go into spoilers here
but let's just say that this is very
similar to the traits of the character
that he was made from as well so this
means that the other high ends that
we've seen who were all in my opinion a
little bit too excited to go crazy and
start killing heroes it's safe to assume
that these were made from some absolute
maniacs but to conclude the high ends
far outrank regular noemi's because of
their super regeneration amazing quirks
I mean how are you storing no moves
within yourself but most importantly
their intelligence that is what makes
them so special it's basically like
fighting a bunch of awful ones I mean
they have multiple quirks
they are super regeneration which all
for one doesn't actually have himself
and they're intelligent they can make
tactical decisions you're pretty screwed
when you come up against these guys so
putting it simply they are just super
annoying as it takes a massive massive
effort to defeat them and they're not
even the main bad guys like you
to defeat them before you get to sugar
Aki but anyway guys those are the higher
no move explained will see them properly
animated in season five maybe a bit in
season four depending on how the pacing
goes be sure to subscribe as I have a
video coming explaining the full
backstory of catch you next time guys
peace